صحه رمضانكم هنا الجزائر
[موسيقى]
مع اذان المغرب الشهر الفضيل اعتاد
الجزائريون على اداء صلاه المغرب مباشره
بعد كسر صيامهم بالتمر والحليب والزلابيه
في مدن بني مزاب بالجنوب تبرز عاده خلفها
الاستعمار الفرنسي اذ كان يمنع صوت الاذان
في الجزائر لكن شعبها تمرد واطحن الاطفال
مع صوت الاذان يدقون اعمده الكهرباء في
الشوارع او يضرب الاهالي طلقات بارود
لاعلان ساعه الافطار على اطباق مميزه في
الصحراء الجزائريه كالمسفوف تتميز سفره
رمضان في الجزائر باطباق تقليديه منها
الشخشوخه والشوربه والبراك والحريره
والطعام او الكسكسي والرشته والشلاظه
وتبرز اطباق رمضانيه خاصه مثل طاجين الحلو
المزين بشباح الصفره عند القسنطينيين مثلا
والسفه عند الوهرانيين
في الجزائر ايضا وبالتحديد في النصفيه
والمقصود هنا ليله النصف من رمضان تحتفل
بعض العائلات بختان اطفالها
بسم الله بديت
واعلن بيصليت وعلى الصحابه رضيت وليكم يا
البنات هاد البقالات كما تقام سهرات نسويه
تحكى فيها حكم واقوال شعبيه وتعقد فيما
يسميه الجزائريون بجلسه البقاله
مظاهر التكافل لا تخلو في الجزائر
تزين الشوارع ببسط فوائد الرحمن ويتم
توزيع قفه رمضان على الاسر المتعففه
[موسيقى]
اطباق شهيه ما شاء الله
في الارض ولا في السماء وهو السميع العليم
في ولايه قسنطينه حيث يتم استقبال رمضان
باحياء ما تعرف بعاده الشعبانيه حيث يجتمع
اهل البيت في حفل للتجميع الاعانات
للفقراء في صوره تعكس تكاتف افراد المجتمع
الجزائري
العلاج ورمضان سعيد الهلال
بالبركه والعام جديد للهلادو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]